Today we're going to discuss the statute of frauds which concerns the kinds of
agreements that must be in writing in order to be enforceable if an agreement
falls within the statute,
then having a written contract is a requirement for enforcing the promises.
In the agreement we'll discuss the historical origins and context of the
statute,
the types of transactions that fall within the statute and the requirements for
fulfilling the statutes,
uh,
itself and the consequences of noncompliance and varying judicial
interpretations of the statute.
Let's start with some historical background.
In 1677 the English parliament passed the precursor to the modern American
statute of frauds.
It was called an act for prevention of frauds and surgeries.
The act was meant to prevent individuals from falsely claiming that another
party had promised them something and from then assuming that party for breach
of the alleged contract,
this kind of false claim was particularly pernicious because in England at the
time of the statutes,
enactment interested parties to litigation.
That is the parties who had a real stake in the outcome of the lawsuit.
The plaintiff and defendant were not permitted to testify in court.
If a claimed that be agreed to sell him a plot of land and then breach their
contract.
The neither a nor B could testify about the alleged agreement to combat this
phenomenon.
The act for prevention of frauds and perjurious required that certain kinds of
contracts had to be in writing and signed.
Section four of the act required that no action shall be brought unless the
agreement upon which such action shall be brought shall be in writing and signed
by the parties to be charged there with or some other person there unto by him a
lawfully authorized for certain types of actions.
These included suing one for a green and failing to pay another's debts,
suing for violation of agreements made on consideration of marriage,
suing on agreements for the sale of land and suing on agreements that could not
be performed within a year.
Section four has been widely imitated since then and as the restatement second
of contracts.
Section one 10 makes clear and you can see here basically the same provisions
appearing,
uh,
almost word for word section 17 of this 1677 statute of frauds govern the sale
of goods.
It provided no contract for the sale of any goods for the price of 10 pounds,
sterling or upwards shall be allowed to be good except the buyer shall accept
part of the goods sold or give something in earnest to bind the bargain or that
some note or memorandum in writing of said bargain be made and signed by the
parties to be charged by such contract.
That section too,
she's a very similar counterpart in the UCC in section two Dash Two oh one
subsection one provides that a contract for the sale of goods for a price of
$500 or more is not enforceable unless there is some writing sufficient to
indicate that a contract for sale has been made between the parties and signed
by the party against whom enforcement is sought.
A writing is not insufficient because it admits or incur incorrectly states a
term agreed upon,
but the contract's not enforceable under this provision.
Beyond the quantity of goods shown in the in the writing,
the provision only requires signing by the party against whom enforcement is
sought because the seeker is not denying the existence of the contract.
It's only the other side.
But subsection three of this provision lists some ex,
uh,
exceptions,
a contract which does not satisfy the requirements of subsection one,
but which is valid in other respects,
is enforceable.
A,
if the goods are to be specially manufactured for the buyer and are not suitable
for sale to others in the ordinary course of business.
B,
if the party against whom enforcement is sought admits in his pleading testimony
or otherwise in court,
that a contract for sale was made or see with respect to goods for which payment
has been made and accepted or which have been received and accepted,
admitting that a contract was made and a buyer's payment or acceptance of goods
is a fairly good substitute for a buyer signature.
But especially manufacture goods might substitute for a seller signature as an
indication that the seller must have thought there was a contract or wouldn't
have produced these specially manufactured goods.
So here's a question.
The statute of frauds was meant to address false allegations that agreement
existed,
but in addressing that process problem,
could the statute promote another kind of fraud?
Well,
sadly,
the answer is yes,
it might encourage the converse concern alleging no agreement existed when in
fact in agreement did without the statute of frauds were apt to see false
allegations of contract,
uh,
when the parties never in fact agreed.
But with the statute,
we're apt to see false denials of contracts where the parties actually did agree
parties can protect themselves from denial fraud by insisting that the other
side to a contract always sign an agreement,
then she can't deny the contracts existence.
While false allegations of oral contracting are much harder to disprove.
So we might on balance prefer the statute and rely on parties incentives to
insist on written contracts to avoid denial fraud.
Sadly,
parties still make many oral arguments make many oral contracts that are not
reduced to writing.
And so the statute of frauds actually promotes,
uh,
some fraudulent deniers to escape liability for breaching their actual promises.
This is one of the reasons why the statute has been repealed in of all places,
the jurisdiction of its birth England
complying with the statute.
The statute of Fart frauds requires not only that contract's being writing,
but also that they'd be signed.
Think for a moment of the kinds of contracts you have entered when you shop
online.
For instance,
did you sign those agreements?
The official comment to the UCC two two oh one says that the word signed
includes any authentication which identifies the party to be charged.
Generally,
courts take a broad view of what constitutes as a signature.
The restatement second of contracts,
one 34 says,
is that the signature may be any symbol,
uh,
or adopted with an intention,
actual or apparent to authenticate the writing as that of the signers.
So A and B agreed to a contract,
the terms of which a makes a written record a rights.
Okay.
Followed by Aes initial at the top of this record.
Does this qualify as a signature by a
well,
the answer is yes.
As the UCC and restatements suggests courts have taken a broad view of what
counts as a signature.
I sent it a few minutes ago.
The fact that many transactions now place electronically sits awkwardly with
requirements that certain contracts be written accordingly.
In 2008,
Congress passed the electronics records and signature in commerce act,
also known as the e sign act.
This act provides signature contract or rather record relating to a transaction.
Uh,
may not be denied legal effect validity or enforceability solely because it's in
electronic form.
And that a contract relating to such transaction may not be denied legal effect
or enforceability because an electronic signature or an electronic record was
used in its formation.
Further,
almost every state has adopted the uniform electronic transaction act.
The only two non enacting states are New York and Washington,
which overlaps significantly with east sign,
but it's even more comprehensive in allowing you to,
uh,
sign,
for,
uh,
Internet contract by just clicking through.
Uh,
so what happens if parties fail to comply with the statute of frauds?
A failure to have a writing and a s a sufficient signature doesn't render an
oral agreement automatically avoid rather an oral agreement that falls within
the statute of frauds,
uh,
but is does not meet its requirement will be unenforceable at the option of the
party against whom enforcement of the agreement is sought.
In legal terms,
it's voidable not void.
So if a and B orally agree that be,
we'll sell a several acres of land and the parties never put that agreement in
writing and afterward be fails to sell the land to a,
a sues B and the contract will be unenforceable if be raises as a defense that
the statute of fraud requires such an agreement to be in writing.
Jurisdictions differ on whether a person raising the statute of frauds,
defense needs to promise or represent under oath that there was in fact no
agreement.
Does the seller in the land hypothetical just given above,
have to say there was no agreement in a deposition,
for example.
Whereas there,
uh,
her attorney signing a of a brief,
that resists,
that raises this defense.
Is the attorney signing sufficient to make a claim of there not being a
contract.
Previously we discussed promissory Estoppel and the famous section of the
restatement section 90,
uh,
which is the promissory estoppel section.
What happens if someone makes an oral promise that falls within the statute of
frauds and the other party relies upon it?
Well,
section one 39 of the restatement addresses this and repeats the language at the
elements of section 90 saying that the agreement is enforceable not withstanding
the statute of frauds if injustice can be avoided only by enforcement of the
promise.
What about the UCC?
There's disagreement over whether promissory Estoppel can be used to save an
oral sales contract that falls within the statute,
but which is not in writing.
Uh,
under the UCC,
the inconsistency extends not just between,
but within jurisdictions.
See,
for example,
the seventh circuit's opinion in Manetti versus anchor hocking corporation.
They're the court outlined some of the arguments for and against applying
promissory Estoppel to save an agreement that failed to meet the statute of
frauds requirements under the UCC.
That opinion explained that it had in past cases,
quote cut loose promissory Estoppel from contract law and permitted promissory
Estoppel in statute of frauds cases.
By that it was having second thoughts lately.
So what have we learned?
We've learned that certain kinds of contracts must be in writing in order to be
enforceable,
and that this work requirement has deep historic origins,
were familiar with the basic types of contracts that fall within the ambit of
the statute of frauds contracts to buy and sell goods over $500 contracts to buy
or sell real property contracts that cannot be performed within one year and
contracts offering something in return for a marriage promise and finally
agreements to pay another person's debt.
But we've also learned that parties often can pursue promissory estoppel
theories just as if the agreement in question weren't one to which the statute
of frauds applied.